vous voulez créer une chaîne youtube est
pour l'instant est quelque chose qui
cloche
il faut absolument avoir une vraie
proposition avoir une vraie valeur
ajoutée est quelque chose qui se
différencie des autres on va regarder
ensemble comment on peut solutionner ce
problème et comment avoir une chaîne
youtube qui cartonne de plus en plus de
chaînes youtube voit le jour et il est
extrêmement difficile de réussir
je partage avec vous toute mes astuces
et mes meilleures techniques pour avoir
plus de vue gagner des abonnés et enfin
réussir sur youtube inscrivez-vous à ma
chaîne activer la cloche pour ne manquer
aucune publication question du jour
quelle est la proposition de votre
chaîne quelle est sa plus value qu'est
ce qu'elle apporte est que d'autres
chaînes n'apporte pas mettez moi ça en
commentaire et on en parle ensemble en
commentaire il ya de plus en plus de
chaînes youtube certaines ont une vraie
valeur ajoutée y apporte quelque chose
de réellement différent et du coup
peuvent progresser et réussir alors que
d'autres font sensiblement la même chose
de choses déjà existantes et du coup ça
marche pas une des clés pour réussir sur
youtube c'est d'avoir une vraie
proposition avoir une vraie plus-value
quelque chose de neuf
un concept neuf une haute vision une
autre façon de voir les choses
on peut traiter d'un même sujet mais on
peut le prendre sous différents taxi par
exemple vous parlez de gainey il ya
plein de façons de parler de gaming vous
pouvez déjà par exemple avoir une
proposition en parlant d'un type de jeu
sous un angle particulier d'une façon
qui n'a pas été fait quelque chose de
neuf à porter un oeil neuf apporter
quelque chose de différent à voir votre
voix votre propre voix votre voix est
unique et c'est ça qui fera votre succès
et c'est pour cette raison que les gens
s'abonnent rouen bochen souvent pour vos
sens et sur youtube c'est parce qu'on
aime déjà des gros youtuber on aime
certaines chaînes et on rêverait de
faire comme eux sauf que si on fait la
même chose qu'eux on peut être sûrs
quasiment à 100% que ça ne marchera pas
pourquoi est ce que quelqu'un viendrait
s'abonner à votre chaîne alors qu'il
peux déjà regarder le gros youtuber que
vous admirez vous aussi au final si vous
faites la même chose si vous n'êtes
qu'une pâle copie ça ne peut pas marcher
rassurez vous il ya de la place sur
youtube il ya de la place pour tout le
monde pour une nouvelle inspiration et
pour de nouvelles voies à vous trouver
la vôtre
moi par exemple quand j'ai débuté sur
youtube j'étais un grand fan de certains
blogs que je regardais et je me suis dit
pourquoi pas créer le mien autour d'eux
au tourne à vie de famille sauf que en
réalité j'ai d'une créer quelque chose
qui n'apportait strictement rien de deux
je les fais beaucoup moins bien que les
autres et de troyes s'était
particulièrement pas intéressant si vous
voulez voir ce que c'est allé voir dans
mes vidéos regardées les plus anciennes
et vous le verrez que franchement ça
n'apporte pas grand chose
alors comme tout youtuber à un moment on
se lance on a très envie on extrêmement
motivé on se met à créer énormément fait
beaucoup de contenu et puis on se rend
compte que notre contenu ne marche pas
on se lasse on est démotivé et on a
envie d'arrêter
et c'est justement à ce moment là qu'il
faut se poser les bonnes questions il
faut déjà que vous trouviez votre niche
trouver votre sujet trouver un sujet sur
un point précis de quels sujets vous
allez parler comment vous allez traiter
si vous parlez de high tech il faut
pareil que vous parliez dans certains
types de produits que vous ayez une
vraie expertise que vous ayez vraiment
quelque chose en plus à apporter
il faut imaginer un spectateur se mettre
à sa place s'il arrive sur votre chaîne
s'est déjà probablement qui vous a
trouvé dans les suggestions ou dans les
résultats de recherche
ensuite il part regarder vos vidéos et
s'il y a une vraie plus value est un
vrai intérêt qui correspond à ses
besoins et pas aux autres
il va s'abonner c'est très très
important à ce moment crucial de votre
carrière youtube si on peut appeler ça
comme ça de savoir se remettre en
question prendre une feuille blanche et
tout noté de quoi est ce que vous parlez
comment est ce que vous allez en parler
est ce que donne youtuber le font déjà
si oui de quelle manière comment est ce
que vous pouvez vous différencier c'est
extrêmement important il faut que vous
trouviez votre propre voix je vous
invite à aller jeter un petit coup
d'oeil sur ma fiche qui va donner les 10
astuces indispensables pour bien débuter
sa chaîne youtube ça vous donnera une
ligne stratégique vous pourrez voir les
dix points essentiels pour pouvoir bien
débuté dans de bonnes conditions sur
youtube qui posez vous une question quel
est votre but en faisant vos vidéos
youtube est ce que le but c'est d'abord
du succès plein d'abonnés d'être connu
et d'or de la notoriété
si c'est ça votre but ça ne peut pas
marcher parce que les gens qui vous
regardent le sentiront ils verront
directement le but ne peut pas être le
succès le succès n'est jamais qu'une
conséquence le but ça doit être partager
votre expérience partager votre
expertise partager quelque chose de neuf
apporter quelque chose à la communauté
youtube il faut absolument créer une
chaîne dont on se souviendra
c'est super important
attention à vos éléments de marque quel
est votre logo quel est votre photo quel
est votre bannière quel est le nom de
votre chaîne comment sont faites vos
vignette est ce que vous avez un système
pour pouvoir effectivement promouvoir
vos vignette pour que les gens
découvrent vidéo ait envie de cliquer
dessus
il faut tout simplement imaginer que
quelqu'un qui va penser à votre
thématique et à votre problématique
pense directement à vous parce que vous
aurez une marque forte
alors une marque se crée pas du jour au
lendemain mais il faut vraiment avoir ça
en tête ça vous donnera un cap ça vous
donnera un but pour pouvoir
effectivement réussir ensuite quelque
chose qui est très important c'est
d'identifier les points à corriger
une fois que vous soyez vraiment
critique envers vous ne demandez pas à
vos amis la plupart du temps vos ennemis
vous donneront des fausses critiques
ils seront plutôt indulgent envers vous
voudront pas vous blesser et du coup
vous pensez que ce que vous faites est
super ce sont les gens qui ne vous
comprennent pas qu'ils vous découvre mal
ou que youtube ne marche mal soyez
extrêmement critique envers vous
n'essayez pas par exemple dans cette
vidéo à mettre un commentaire et a
demandé à d'autres youtuber d'aller voir
votre chaîne et de dire ce qui va ce qui
ne va pas c'est extrêmement important
d'avoir des critiques pas pour se faire
démolir mais juste pour avoir des points
d'amélioration souvent la plus grosse
erreur c'est qu'effectivement on n'est
pas dans une niche on apporte pas
quelque chose de neuf mais après il peut
y avoir des aliments de l'eau quand est
ce que vous vous exprimez bien est-ce
que vous avez une bonne élocution est ce
que techniquement ça marchait ce que le
son est ok est ce que la lumière est ok
est ce que la qualité de votre caméra
fonctionne bien est ce que le fonds va
bien aussi
n'oubliez pas que c'est extrêmement
important d'accrocher le spectateur dans
les dix premières secondes de votre
vidéo quelqu'un qui ne vous connaît pas
qui va arriver sur votre vidéo doit être
accroché directement de se dire c'est ça
que je veux voir ça c'est très très
important
posez vous la question est ce que votre
thématique est clairement défini est ce
qu'on arrive en sens votre chaîne va
tout de suite comprendre de quoi il
parle
et aussi posez vous la question de votre
légitimité il faut vraiment que vous
ayez une expertise que vous ayez une
expérience à partager quelque chose à
dire avoir une voix en plus mais pas
juste faire des vidéos pour faire des
vidéos parce que ça ne peut pas
fonctionner quelqu'un qui arrive sur
votre chaîne cherche une réponse à une
question du moins la plupart du temps
c'est ça si vous n'avez pas d' expertise
si vous n'avez pas de légitimité les
gens partiront par exemple si vous avez
100 abonnés voire 200 500 abonnés et que
vous voulez faire une chaîne pour savoir
comment agir sur youtube
ça n'est pas possible tout simplement
parce que vous n'avez pas la légitimité
moi aujourd'hui si je me permets de vous
parler de cette thématique c'est parce
que j'ai déjà une base d'abonnés qui est
présente et surtout parce que j'ai des
vidéos qui se sont extrêmement bien
référencés j'ai compris comment marcher
de l'algorithme youtube j'ai compris
comment on faisait pour référencer ses
vidéos et c'est ça qui me permet de
partager mon expérience avec vous il
faut vraiment prendre tous ces points en
considération posez-vous toutes ces
questions prenez du temps
n'hésitez pas à faire un break remettez
tout à zéro remettez tout à plat posé
des questions en commentaire on en
discute et vous verrez que tout va
s'éclairer et tout va s'ouvrir
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo ci et
vous apporter des éléments de réponse
n'hésitez pas mais sa jolie pousse à
vous abonner souhaite toujours plus
d'astuces et de bonnes techniques et de
bonnes pratiques pour faire évoluer
votre chaîne pour gagner des vues et les
convertir en abonnés quant à moi je vous
remercie je vous dis à très bientôt
salut